I'm gonna take up cycling but I'm doing
reverse I'll do it with my hands what do
you mean like I'm gonna pedal the bike
with my arms you can get like a
recumbent bike that you can no no I'm
gonna put my chest on the seat oh nice
my legs up in there split yeah yeah yeah
no actually I'll just be like in a
Superman pose like flat on the seat yeah
my legs yeah yeah
I've never seen this video you've never
seen this no yeah this went crazy on
Twitter why does no one do this he must
be going like 50 miles an hour this is
how the Lance Armstrong won those races
dude yeah he's about to beat a moped
homie
oh my God a little speed wall dude the
pedal yeah the pedals are going so fast
oh easy boom that's impressive